In this video we'll be discussing the system requirements for a Kubernetes deployment of
Burp Suite Enterprise Edition. Please note that we recommend that you only attempt to deploy and
manage enterprise in a Kubernetes environment if you have previous Kubernetes experience,
otherwise we would advise using the standard installer process. Now we provide a Helm chart
with the correct field values to meet the minimum system requirements and you can access this from
the Burp release page. To begin you'll need a cluster that meets the following requirements,
an ingress solution, for example a load balancer or an ingress controller,
a persistent volume claim called application-name-pvc and that can be shared by all nodes in
the namespace where Burp Suite Enterprise Edition is deployed. Additionally to enable cluster node
auto scaling the cluster auto scaler must be installed and enabled and finally an external
database that meets our system requirements, the documentation to which you can refer to in the
link below. Burp Suite Enterprise Edition can run on any x86-based cluster. There may be additional
infrastructure configuration required depending on your Kubernetes environment. You can also refer to
our Kubernetes support scope and deployment guide documentation again linked below.
Finally if you refer to our system requirement documentation you can see the container system
requirements. We specify these values in our Helm chart values file and you can configure these custom
values yourselves if desired but again these are the minimums that are required. Please note we would
advise that your cluster node type is set appropriately for your environment and CentOS and Red Hat version 7
operating systems are not supported for the cluster worker node. Finally if you need any assistance with
the system requirements or designing your deployment please email our support team at support at portswigger.net
and we shall endeavor to assist you. Thank you.